he had to throw that in about being a
former Marxist huh
okay I guess I better look out here
but I'll remind you that Thomas Sal is a
former former Marxist
uh David Horowitz is a former Marxist
the best fighters against Marxism are
former marxists
[Applause]
so today I'm going to talk about
the rise of corporate fascism but the
title of the talk is woke capitalism is
economic fascism
so we're going to begin by
addressing just what I'm talking about
here how is quote capitalism economic
fascism and what's wrong with it
so as we know economic fascism has a
long history dating to the 1920s and 30s
naturally when the word fascism is used
we think of the totalitarian regimes of
Mussolini and Hitler and the Ugly racist
and anti-semitic characteristics of
those regimes
but there was also an economic policy
and component of cap of fascism known in
Europe during the 1920s and 30s as
corporatism
corporatism is the subordination of the
economy to the state and the state's
adoption of favored corporations
corporatism was an essential element of
the economic totalitarianism practice
under Mussolini and Hitler
corporatism was adopted in Italy and
Germany during the 30s and was held up
as a model for policy makers and
intellectuals in the United States and
the rest of the West
a version of economic fascism was in
fact adopted in the United States
in the 30s
and it survives to this day
in the United States these policies were
not called fascism they were called
Planned capitalism
we have witness though of late
uh a parade of economic fascist policies
under the dividing Administration
with its 12 plus executive orders
directed at climate change and even its
chips and science Act
um all of which are
uh
instances of economic fascist
intervention
so today economic fascism or corporatism
flies under an entirely different Banner
today we see it called woke capitalism
by its critics or by its proponents
stakeholder capitalism so it's
stakeholder capitalism and what
capitalism that I'll talk about
and these two
in fact I'll say are the same
and I'm going to try to explain to you
just why these corporations have adopted
leftism
exactly what's in it for them
okay
so stakeholder capitalism we're told is
a form of capitalism that benefits
customers suppliers employees the local
communities society and the planet
in addition to shareholders
a stakeholder is supposedly anyone that
stands to benefit or lose from corporate
Behavior other than competitors we may
suppose
stakeholder capitalism involves changes
to the behavior of Corporations with
respect to carbon-based energy use
but also in terms of the distrib
distribution of benefits and
externalities that corporations produce
it means not only corporate cooperation
but also major governmental intervention
in the economy
however as the sink from standard
corporatism
it is being driven first and foremost by
corporations themselves
and only later is endorsed and enforced
by the state
the stakeholder capitalism includes not
only corporate State responses to
ecological issues such as climate change
and also
climate change but also
rethinking their commitments to already
vulnerable communities within their
ecosystem system says Paul Schwab
this is the social justice aspect of
stakeholder capitalism these special
stakeholders are supposed to include
women and black brown indigenous
transgender and other special identity
groups who supposedly stand to benefit
from this stakeholderism
however they don't
its proponents pits stakeholder
capitalism against what they're called
neoliberalism
now neoliberalism is a weasel word
that is used by different people to mean
different things
but claw swab and his co-author Thierry
malarat they use the term to refer to
what is otherwise known as the free
market this is the enemy of stakeholder
capitalism
the free market
uh is to them a corpus of ideas and
policies that can Loosely be defined as
favoring competition over solidarity
creative destruction over government
intervention and economic growth over
social welfare as if those terms
economic growth and social welfare can
be opposed that's the absurdity here
stakeholder capitalism thus is opposed
to free market the free market system to
capitalism itself
now we're told that stakeholder
capitalism will benefit all these
stakeholders but in interfering with the
market economy
stakeholder capitalism represents a
grave Injustice to the real stakeholders
of businesses not only their
stockholders or owners employees and
customers but also Society at Large
today I mean to show you just how
stakeholder or woke capitalism poses a
threat not only to the free enterprise
system but also to individual liberty
and a free Society
so
let's take a little foray into popular
culture
what is who is Dr Evil
General Motors Super Bowl advertisement
Dr Evil this was the 2022 Super Bowl
last year
summon viewers to ponder the issue of
climate change
the ad introduced the company's electric
vehicles stylized as EVS before
apparently committing the corporation to
a net zero
future in the same breath GM subtly
suggested what it purported to be a
looming catastrophe of climate change
ladies and gentlemen our takeover of
General Motors is complete Dr Abel we
can now use GM's ultium platform to
power our whole operation now we can
reduce tailpipe emissions I'm sorry am I
no longer Dr Evil I'm Dr good now I
didn't get the meme climate change is
arguably the number one threat to the
world now Dr Abel you are now the number
two threat to the world I refuse to be
number two number two we have to help
the plan oh please cheer for myself
your son I shall name him
baby me no his name is Kyle
oh you must help save the world first
then you can take over okay Pharrell how
about you let me do the business all
right hold on I've got it I will help
save the world first then take over the
world she literally just said that
Scott you just don't get it do you what
what don't I get you didn't get it oh
we're right back you're never gonna get
it you can't draw me in this little you
act like a child you know damn an adult
with my buttons anymore
oh where would I do start a comment
Footprints whatever okay let's go we're
going oh no that trick
not you skull
one day you're gonna run the company
baby me
[Music]
so the ad reprises the theme of the
Austin power series
Mike Myers Seth Green Rob Lowe and Mindy
Sterling play Dr Evil
Dr Evil's son Scott number two and Frau
fabricina respectively
as his cohorts inform him despite having
taken over GM Dr Evil has been displaced
by climate change from his position as
the world's number one threat not to be
outdone nor to have his plans for world
domination thwarted Dr Evil co-ops Frau
farbestina's words
vowing to take regain his number one
position by becoming part of the climate
solution I will help take over the world
first then save the world
the irony of doctor of GM's Dr Evil
appropriation was not lost on Gizmodo
columnist Molly Taft for whom GM is a
real-life super villain openly
pretending to be a superhero and making
its pretensions blatant
she writes GM's long history of climate
denial makes this ad painfully literal
and is a warning about how polluting
companies are now trying to greenwash
their reputations
but for Taft GM is Dr Evil himself
marshalling this iconic character is too
clever by half and cuts matters too
close to the Bone
now the edge should strike us as ironic
too but GM's play for a adoption of Dr
Evil was a joke on such observers as
Taft
the company ironically suggested that it
is not the criminal force that Taft and
others have made it out to be after all
Dr Evil is a fictional villain and not
the real CEO of of GM
but even more ironic is perhaps GM's
perhaps unintentional representation of
the world economic forum
just as GM appropriated Dr Evil and Dr
Evil appropriated Frau Farber Cena the
ads seemed to reference the Mian and
Ethos of klosh Schwab
the chairman and founder of the wef or
World economic forum who has been
popularly likened
to the villain
Schwab is the world's leading corporate
mouthpiece of climate change
catastrophism
he and his corporate stakeholders signed
on to the wf's agenda also stand again
outside economic and political power as
this agenda is enacted through his
brainchild stakeholder capitalism
its environmental social and governance
index the ESG already measures corporate
compliance with the agenda
stakeholder capitalism makes partners of
corporations in the world's governance
system as well while advancing their
monopolistic economic ambitions
now does GM
uh
does GM really mean to
appropriate Claus Schwab
whether the
whether the appropriation is conscious
or not
the ad nevertheless recalled Schwab's
stakeholderism and given the prevalence
of the comparison of Dr Evil and cloth
Schwab all over the internet
and the expenditures for the ad which
had to be in the multi-millions
it is highly unlikely that the creative
team was unaware of this comp comparison
but whether the inflation of suave's
intentional or not the ad nevertheless
issued a biting tongue-in-cheek
criticism of the agenda that GM and
consumers are being compelled to accept
furthermore the Dr Evil ad tacitly
acknowledges that something is evil
afoot with the establishment of
stakeholder capitalism no matter how
much the wef and its corporate Partners
glossed the project in terms of equity
and sustainability the sense that an
evil is a agenda is being conducted
under the imperatives of stakeholder
capitalism is irresistible
now this has also been called woe
capitalism
the phrase woe capitalism was coined by
a New York Times editorialist Ross du
taught
it was used to describe a new form
a new uh corporate activism in line with
the woke agenda the promotion by Fork
profit corporations of identity politics
gender Pro pluralism
transgender rights lacks immigration
standards voting reform
climate change mitigation and so on you
know the list
upon coming coining the term to thought
uh ventured to explain it he essentially
suggested that woke capitalism works by
substituting symbolic value for economic
value
that is under under woke capitalism
corporations offer workers and consumers
a rhetorical Placebo in place of real
costlier concessions such as higher
wages or better benefits or lower prices
the same gestures of wokeness also
appeal to the elite the liberal Elite
political Elite whom the world
corporation's hope will spare them
higher taxes as Matt was pointing out
increased regulations and Anti-Trust
legislation aimed at monopolies